dernier sujet je voudrais aborder c'est
finalement le sujet global de
l'anticipation et de la gestion du temps
on a beaucoup parlé des projets se verra
à souligné d'autres l'ont fait
d'ailleurs le fait que
on a un parc nucléaire existant qui a
été construit à 75 % dans les années 80
donc on a beaucoup de réacteurs qui vont
vivre à peu près en même temps et
lorsque l'on regarde les projections sur
un mix énergétique à 2050 et après 2050
et c'est la question aussi du nombre de
pair2 on voit bien que tous ces
réacteurs vont atteindre à peu près 70
ans 70 ans c'est plus que la durée de
vie pour laquelle aujourd'hui nous nous
sommes prononcés pour les réacteurs
actuels les éléments qui nous ont été
fournis par EDF nous ont permis de nous
positionner jusqu'à 50 ans pas au-delà
donc première message que je veux faire
passer c'est que dans le débat certes il
y a le débat que vous avez qui est celui
de des projets de nouveaux nucléaires
mais pas dans le projet de loi que nous
ici mais plus tard dans le projet de loi
de l'année prochaine il faut absolument
s'interroger sur les mesures
d'accompagnement qui permettront de
donner de la visibilité et d'anticiper
l'échéance 2050 pour les réacteurs en
service il faut le faire avec beaucoup
de temps en avance donc je répète c'est
un message que j'avais déjà fait passer
il faut que dans les quelques années qui
viennent nous ayons une vraie analyse de
fond pour savoir quel peut être la durée
de vie du parc des réacteurs nucléaires
d'EDF et avec suffisamment
d'anticipation pour pouvoir ajuster les
les résultats en tout cas les
conséquences qui peuvent être d'ailleurs
des conséquences attirer sur le nombre
de réacteurs à décider donc il faut lier
les deux on ne peut pas s'intéresser
uniquement sur les nouveaux réacteurs en
séparant la question des réacteurs
actuels sur leur durée de vie nous
n'avons pas ces justifications et moi je
ne souhaite pas en tant que président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire que la
poursuite d'exploitation des réacteurs
du cadre en France soit la variable
d'ajustement d'une politique énergétique
qui aurait été mal calibrée c'est
essentiel il faut lier les deux sujets
[Musique]